I was born in Peru but I spent my first
10 years not in Peru but in Bolivia then
when we returned to Peru I live in pura
in lima and then I have lived in Spain
in France in England in the United
States and I've been moving all the way
I think my my Peruvian roots are very
important for me because the first
images that my memory has preserved are
related to to Peru the kind of Spanish
that I speak is the Peruvian Spanish
which of course is part of the of the
Spanish but with certain nuances with a
certain music and in this sense I can
say that I am a Peruvian writer but I am
NOT nationalistic I am an declare enemy
of all forms of nationalism so I think
for me has been as important as to be
born in Peru to have spent so many years
in France so many years in England and
then I think all all places in which I
have lived have produced the writer that
I am now I think this is another very
important knowledge that you receive
being a writer everything that you do is
something that contributes to build your
personality to build your sensibility
and and I think this nationalistic
vision is so limited
he saw provincial put you in such
restricted space to understand problems
to understand life that is very very
important to liberate yourself of this
kind of free journalistic or
nationalistic perspective
and I think that should help you a lot
to overcome this very limited
perspective of life what do you discover
reading you know author from different
languages from different traditions is
that the common denominator is much more
important much more larger than this
local istic you know regional is taken
as annalistic kind of perspective so in
this sense I consider myself a citizen
of the of the world and I think and I
think literature has helped me very much
to have this attitude I belong of course
to Peru but I belong to Latin America I
belong to the spanish-speaking world
which means a lot of traditions and and
at the same time I feel in a way that I
owe a lot to French culture to English
culture to culture of of my my time and
I would like very much a world in which
people from all places consider
themselves belonging to all places and
achieve this kind of goal through
cultures I think culture is the great
instrument to overcome the geographical
or cultural or religious limitations
that you have and understand the rest
and participate of everything that is
good important beautiful in other
cultures in northern traditions in other
countries